CONGRESS.
>> MORE COMING UP ON THE PANEL.
THANK, MIKE EMANUEL FROM CAPITOL
HILL.
THIS IS ANOTHER FOX NEWS ALERT
WITH THE CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE
JUDICIARIES COMMITTEE.
MAKING A REQUEST FOR A SECOND
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
THAT WAS MADE WITH SAVINGS.
-- JEFF SESSIONS.
TWO CHAIRMAN MEN ARE WITH ME
NOW.
BOB AND TRAY.
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME HERE.
YOU STATE MATTERS HAVE ARISEN.
WHAT CHANGED?
>> WHAT CHANGED FOR ME THERE ARE
TWO DOZEN WITNESSES THAT
HOROWITZ WOULD NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO.
LET THE INSPECTOR GENERAL DO IT.
MIKE HOROWITZ HAS NO
JURISDICTION OVER WITNESSES WHO
NEVER WORKED THERE.
WHEN I COUNTED UP 24 WITNESSES
THAT HE WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
ACCESS WERE HE TO INVESTIGATE
IT, ONLY ONE CONCLUSION.
THAT'S SPECIAL COUNSEL.
>> WHO IS ON THAT LIST?
>> EVERYBODY FROM JIM COMBY TO
MCCABE, SIDNEY BLOOMENTHAL.
ANYBODY WHO NO LONGER WORKS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE OR THE
FBI.
STATE DEPARTMENT EMPLOYEES WERE
FEEDING INFORMATION TO FUSION
GPS.
ANYONE WHO IS NOT AN EMPLOYEE OF
DOJ HOROWITZ DOESN'T HAVE
SUBPOENA POWER FOR THEM.
>> THERE WAS A REPORT THAT
MCCABE WAS THE LEAKER OF THE
HILLARY CLINTON REPORT S. THAT
TRUE?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> YOU SAID ABOUT THE FISA
COURTS.
SPECIFICALLY THE PROCESS WAS
ABUSED.
HOW?
>> WELL, IT WAS ABUSED BY A
GATHERING OF INFORMATION FROM A
VERY SUSPECT SOURCE, NOT
DISCLOSING THAT INFORMATION TO
THE COURT.
IN MY OPINION, GETTING AUTHORITY
TO LOOK INTO THE BACKGROUND OF
AN AMERICAN CITIZEN'S LIFE ON
QUESTIONABLE CIRCUMSTANCES.
THAT'S A VERY SERIOUS CONCERN.
THE FBI IS AMERICA'S PREMIER LAW
ENFORCEMENT ORGANIZATION.
EVERY DAY THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF GREAT MEN AND WOMEN
KEEP US SAFE.
INVESTIGATE CRIME AND PREVENT
TERROR ATTACKS.
BUT SEVERAL PEOPLE AT THE TOP OF
THIS ORGANIZATION HAVE ENGAGED
IN ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
QUESTIONABLE.
I THINK THAT IN ORDER TO SET THE
RECORD STRAIGHT, CLEAR WHAT IS
GOING ON IN THE FBI AND MAKE
SURE THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN,
WE NEED TO HAVE AN OUTSIDE
SPECIAL COUNSEL INVESTIGATION.
>> LET ME READ FROM YOUR LETTER
ON THE SCREEN.
YOU WRITE THERE WAS EVIDENCE OF
BIAS.
THERE IS EVIDENCE POLITICAL
OPPOSITION RESEARCH WAS USEED IN
COURT FILEINGS AND:
DO YOU HAVE EVIDENCE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WAS SPYING
ON THE TRUMP TEAM DURING THE
ELECTION?
>> THAT'S WHETHER YOU CONSIDER
CARTER PAGE TO BE PART OF THE
TRUMP TEAM?
ABSOLUTELY.
THIS WHOLE FISA WARRANT WAS ON
CARTER PAGE.
YOU WOULD ALSO PICK UP
CONVERSATIONS THAT CARTER PAGE
WAS HAVING WITH OTHERS.
THE ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION, DE
FACTO IS YES.
>> DO YOU AGREE?
>> I AGREE.
IT'S PREMISED ON THE IDEA THAT
MR. PAGE WAS INVOLVED WITH
SOMETHING THEY WANTED TO
INVESTIGATE.
I THINK THE CASE THAT WAS BUILT
FOR THAT IS HIGHLY SUSPECT.
>> WHAT IS WRONG WITH THE IG
DOING HIS JOB?
>> NOTHING.
I WANT HIM TO GO AHEAD.
HE HAS A COUPLE OF TASKS.
ONE IS TO COMPLETE THE
INVESTIGATION INTO HOW THE FBI
HANDLED THE CLINTON EMAIL
MATTER.
THAT'S SEPARATE.
HE'S LOOKED AT MORE THAN ONE
MILLION DOCUMENTS.
THAT SHOULD BE MADE PUBLIC.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TASKED HIM
WITH LOOKING INTO THIS MATTER AS
WELL.
AS TREY NOTED, HE CAN'T DO THE
COMPLETE JOB.
>> DO YOU TRUST THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL?
>> I DEFINITELY WELCOME THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ENCOURAGING
THAT ASPECT OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
I THINK MORE NEEDS TO BE DONE.
I THINK THE WAY TO DO THAT THAT
HELPS THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
THE FBI IS TO TAKE IT OUTSIDE OF
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS SO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE CAN SEE THIS
PROPERLY INVESTIGATED.
>> SOME MAY SUGGEST CONGRESS CAN
DO THIS JOB.
WHAT IS WRONG WITH THAT?
>> ANYONE WHO WATCHED CONGRESS
OVER THE LAST 12 MONTHS.
WE LEAK LIKE SIEVES.
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
INVESTIGATION THE LOCAL DISTRICT
ATTORNEY OR BOB MUELLER THERE
ARE FEWER LEAKS FROM MUELLER
THAN FROM ADAM SHIP.
WE DON'T HAVE THE TOOLS.
WE DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO A GRAND
JURY.
WE CAN'T GRANT IMMUNITY OR
COMPEL TESTIMONY.
HE DON'T PROSECUTE CRIME.
THERE ARE 1,000 REASONS TO LET
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH OR SPECIAL
COUNSEL HANDLE THIS AS OPPOSED
TO CONGRESS.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW WHERE SPECIAL
LEADS.
YOU START WITH A LAND DEAL IN
ARKANSAS AND END UP WITH A BLUE
DRESS.
YOU HAVE NO CONTROL OVER THAT.
>> HMMM.
YOU CAN SET THE JURISDICTION IN
ATTORNEY GENERAL SESSIONS
APPOINTS SPECIAL COUNSEL HE WILL
SET THE JURISDICTION.
THE ONLY REASON MUELLER CAN GO